hi mystery recapped here today I am
going to explain an American mystery
drama film called where the crawdads
sing spoilers ahead watch out and take
care
[Music]
October 30th 1969 two young kids are
riding their bicycles in the woods of
North Carolina when they come across a
dead body terrified they immediately
call for help shortly after two cops
arrive and start investigating the crime
scene one of them notices that the
deceased is Chase Andrews the son of a
wealthy businessman surprisingly there
are no footprints around the area the
cops then notice a nearby Tower and
start climbing it suspecting that
perhaps Chase fell from there once they
reached the top they find a broken gate
this divides both of them the first cop
believes that chase was pushed and
killed while the other thinks it was an
accident sounds like the second cop may
be pushed and killed him I don't know in
the next scene the autopsy report of the
corpse is out it reveals that chase
indeed died of the Fall impact but
something didn't quite add up based on
his injuries he should have been found
facing downwards but it was upwards
hearing this the cops immediately
deduced that it's a murder however they
don't have any evidence not even
fingerprints luckily the doctor knows
where to start he gives them a tiny red
fabric trick which he found on Chase's
corpse later as the cops are hanging out
in a bar they hear some people
discussing the recent murder case all of
them think that a local girl named Kaya
Clark is the murderer and she had a bad
history with Chase with this information
the cops head towards kaia's house it is
a small house located near a swamp they
look around and find a collection of
shells and books they also get their
hands on a red cap possibly the same
cloth whose fiber was found on Chase's
corpse meanwhile Kaia can be seen hiding
from them in the woods at an opportune
time she tries running away but the cops
eventually catch up to her they question
her why she was running but Kaya doesn't
speak a word hence she is taken into
custody later we see her locked up in a
Cell a local lawyer Tom Milton shows up
and inquires if she would be interested
in his Services however Kaya remains
silent it's almost as if she is hiding
something very deep Tom tries to
persuade her by revealing that she is
going to be tried for murder a court
hearing is going to take place soon and
it is certain that she will be found
guilty after all she has a red hat
that's more than enough evidence hearing
this Kaia becomes scared and finally
opens up a better life At first she
describes her childhood and the movie
goes into a flashback it is 1953 and Kai
lives with her four siblings and parents
at first glance it appears as if they
are a happy family but the truth is
exactly the opposite her drunkard father
always punishes her mother for no reason
so one day having had enough she
abruptly leaves following this all of
her four siblings also left the house
one by one now Kaya is left in the care
of her drunkard father alone the latter
raids the nearby swamp for muscles a
type of seafood Kyle also tries her best
to assist her father in work once
they're done collecting for the day they
head to the local shop to sell it the
shop owner Mrs Mabel is a kind woman who
often provides Kaya with food and
clothes she even admits her into a
school but the little girl instantly
becomes a target for the bullies hence
she runs away never to come back again
as the days pass she becomes more
connected to her father and he too
starts being nice one day Kyrie receives
a letter from her mother but since she
cannot read she asks her dad to read it
for her unfortunately as soon as he goes
through it he becomes enraged and yells
at the little girl your mom is not
coming back after this the drunkard
gathers all of her mom's belongings from
the house and burns them little Kaia is
deeply affected by the incident but
little did she know that this was just
the start of her problems the next
morning when she wakes up she finds that
her father has also wandered off now
there is no one to care for her still
Kaya does not give up she collects
muscles from the swamp and sells them to
buy things in return Mrs Mabel also
helps her with groceries from time to
time back in the present Kaya gets a
lovely dress for Mrs Mabel which she
decides to wear for her first court
hearing the lawyer Tom suggests that she
confessed to the crime but pretend that
it was an accident with this she would
get a maximum of 8 to 10 years in prison
however Kaya asserts that she is not a
murderer so she wants to get out of
prison as soon as possible when the
hearing starts Chase's family lawyer
does his best to prove that is guilty he
points out that no one else would have a
better agenda to kill Chase Kyle loved
him a lot and wanted to marry him but he
always refused this is probably why she
called him to the Tower and chucked him
off hearing all of this the crowd also
starts turning on Kaya they are sure
that she is the murderer she loved more
than anybody she had to be the killer
fortunately Tom also turns out to be a
good lawyer he states that no Footprints
were found on the crime scene so
accusing Kyle without any evidence is
unfair meanwhile she goes into another
flashback it is the year 1963. Kaya has
grown up to become a beautiful young
woman she still lives alone in her house
and does everything by herself Kaya has
also developed a keen interest in nature
so whenever she's free she simply roams
around the woods and enjoys the
Tranquility one day however someone
leaves a beautiful feather for her the
next day she receives another one by the
end of the week Kaia has received
several of these feathers and also
letters somebody's out there killing
birds somewhere then one evening a guy
named Tate Walker approaches her and
reveals that he is the one who has been
sending those presents he inquires if
she read the letters and in a sad voice
Kaya replies I can't read thankfully
Tate is a nice guy who is always ready
to help he starts giving Kyle lessons on
how to read and write for the first few
days they meet in the woods and practice
writing then when Kaya becomes
comfortable enough she takes Tate home
and asks him to teach whatever he can
slowly but steadily the smile on Kaya's
face returns and the bond between the
two deepens in the next scene we get to
know that Tate is an ambitious student
who wants to get admitted to a top
university he has applied to a few and
is awaiting results one day he asks Kaya
if she would like to go to the city with
him but she declines Kaya who has spent
all her life in the swamp thinks that
she doesn't belong in the city Tate
knows that she is not going to change
her mind so he gives up oh man I'll
never be as cool as the swamps some
months pass by and the two have now
become a couple they often make out in
the woods and go for walks One day
things get so romantic between them that
they almost end up having intercourse
however at the last second Tate backs
out saying he doesn't want to harm her
in any way he fears impregnating her I
guess they've never heard of condoms out
there in the swamp the following day
Tate finally hears the news that he had
been longing for he is accepted into
Dartmouth his dream College he
immediately goes to share the good news
with Kaya but instead of being happy she
becomes upset Tate mentions that he
wants to do something with his life and
that going to Dartmouth is a once in a
lifetime opportunity for him however
Kaya who has never studied in school
thinks that it is a waste of time and
money she then runs away saying yeah
boys are the same for some days they
remain distant from one another but on
the final night before he leaves Tate
visits Kaya at her home and spends some
quality time with her the next morning
he explains that she knows literally
everything that there is to know about
the fauna and Flora of the place so Tate
provides her a list of Publishers saying
she should write a book and send it to
them Kaya thanks him for this and asks
if their relationship is over in
response Tate promises that he will meet
her on the 4th of July with him gone
Kaya returns back to her monotonous life
however now she has something to keep
her occupied as suggested by Tate she
has started writing books about the
animals and plants of the region a few
months pass by and it's finally the 4th
of July Kaya arrives at the beach early
in the morning to welcome Tate back
unfortunately even after hours of
waiting he doesn't show up Kaya breaks
down in tears thinking that he has left
her for someone else back in the present
the cop who initially investigated the
case is called up to the court without
further Ado he starts taking Chase's
side and explains that there were no
fingerprints or foot marks on or near
the corpse he believes someone erased
them cleverly Tom counters by mentioning
that the prince might have been erased
to high tides which are very frequent in
the area he then whips out a petition
dating a year back which writes that the
tower is severely damaged anyone
climbing it is risking their own lives
hearing this the entire crowd gets
confused and the case swings in kaia's
favor following this the movie again
cuts back to the past this time to the
year 1968. it has been several years
since Tate left so Kaya has already
gotten over him one day she finds some
government officials checking out her
house when she inquires with Mrs Mabel
about it the latter replies that they
are developers who are acquiring land to
build hotels this shocks Kaya as she
cannot even think of leaving the house
hence she gathers all the necessary
paperwork of her house and submits it to
the developer it reveals that she is
indeed the owner but there is one
problem Kyle will have to pay off the
pending tax which amounts to around 800
since she cannot earn this by selling
shells Kyle reverts to writing after
weeks of hard work she finally finishes
a book and sends it off to all the
Publishers from Tate's lift one day
while at the beach Kaya meets a handsome
young man Chase they clearly notice each
other but don't talk however the next
day when they meet again Chase
confidently asks her out on a date Kaya
who hasn't been in a relationship for
years says yes immediately in this way
the two kick-start a relationship and
begin spending most of their days
together the smile on Kai's face also
starts to reappear one day she gets a
reply from one of the Publishers saying
they are ready to print some copies of
her book the news elates Kaya and when
she shares it with Chase he suddenly
asks her to marry him Kaya stares at him
for a few seconds then accepts as a
symbol of approval she puts a seashell
necklace around his neck in the present
Chase's mother has arrived in court to
give her Testament she reveals that the
necklace was not found around her son's
body at the time of his death so she
suspects that Kaya eliminated him took
his necklace and then removed all the
evidence however Tom mentions that they
shouldn't come to a inclusion just
because of a missing necklace I don't
know it was a pretty dope necklace back
in 1968 now Kate finally arrives home
after graduating from Dartmouth
unfortunately the very first sighty sees
is Kaya spending time with another guy
the next day while he is working at the
dock he overhears Chase talking bad
about Kaya he immediately confronts
Chase and the two get into a fight
fortunately they are seen separated by
some other workers that night he goes to
Kaya's house and explains that he
couldn't come back because he was too
focused on his studies but now that he
knows her value he will never leave her
Tate also asserts that chase is a bad
person who likes playing with other
girls feelings sadly Kaya does not
believe any of this so she just asks him
to go away now she just wants to be with
Chase unfortunately one day Kyle learns
that chase is actually engaged to
another girl this breaks her heart so
she ends her relationship promptly
everything is not bad for her though the
next morning Kaya gets the book that she
had published along with a check of five
thousand dollars she will also have to
attend an important press conference in
Greenville Kaya is over the moon to have
earned such a large amount so she
quickly clears the house tax with the
remaining money she renovates her house
just when it seems like Kaya has
forgotten about Chase he shows up in her
life he tries to lie that he only loves
her but Kaya is not having any of that
BS she asks him to go away from her life
but Chase instead tries to force himself
on her when nothing works she smashes
him in the head with a rock before
leaving Kyle warns Chase not to bother
her again or else she will kill him in
the following days she mostly stays
hidden so as not to be seen by Chase
finally after a week she heads to
Greenville and attends the press
conference back in the present tom tries
to prove that chase wasn't in the city
when the murder took place in fact she
was in Greenville attending a press
conference Tom asserts that it is nearly
impossible to board a bus home kill a
guy wipe out all the evidence and then
return at last before concluding his
speech he just mentions that Justice
should be served after a few hours the
judge finally comes to a decision he
says no not guilty he also apologizes to
Kaya for all the accusations and the
time she spent in jail in the next scene
Kaia reconciles with Tate and the two
get married they start living happily in
the swamp doing the same work that they
used to after more than 50 years kaya
passes away in her favorite boat in the
final scene as Tate is going through his
late wife's belongings he comes across
one of her older books in it a chapter
reads sometimes for the prey to live the
Predator must die after this Tate finds
a drawing of Chase in the same locket
Kaya had presented to him it is covered
in blood indicating that she did
actually kill him subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching